to be honest I probably aggravated her  like but I was but the thing is I used  to be a Savage I'm not you know  respectful Mad Men like that how angry  she was at that what's the reason did  you call the police no no no I actually  just said look you what are you doing  you're gonna make me a sandwich with  that yeah  but to be fairly you know what is I I  don't I will say this though I haven't  um I used to not be very self-aware so I  used to do things and then see why  someone would get upset and think what's  that upset that she will actually hold  it nice yeah but I'm like I just think  oh she's just being crazy but now you  know your own red flag yeah but when you  start before